pero
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bienvenidos a corresponsables el
programa de france 24 que los invita a
dar una vuelta al mundo de la mano de
nuestra red de periodistas comenzó en
glasgow escocia la cob 26 la conferencia
sobre el clima de naciones unidas- que
ha sido calificada como la última
oportunidad real para controlar los
efectos del calentamiento global y del
cambio climático efectos que ya pueden
sentirse y vivirse de manera dramática
en la actualidad en la isla italiana de
sicilia los veranos se hacen cada vez
más cálidos con efectos muy graves para
la producción agrícola y en esta ocasión
los más afectados han sido los
apicultores cuya industria reportó
grandes pérdidas la historia la tiene
nuestra corresponsal natalie mendoza
para este apicultor la situación es
complicada mira estas colmenas están
todas vacías completamente abandonadas
por las colonias esto es inaudito para
piero él es uno de los dos mil
apicultores sicilianos este verano
perdió más de la mitad de sus abejas
cuando una ola de calor nunca antes
vista golpeó a toda la región
en estado de estado una tragedia este
verano fue una tragedia por el calor
excesivo las temperaturas se acercaban a
los 50 grados y así las abejas murieron
o huyeron de las colmenas que se
volvieron como hornear cimentaban forma
a consecuencia de las temperaturas
récord e incendios que devastaron la
región miles de hectáreas de tierra
devorada por las llamas destruyendo a su
paso la vegetación imprescindible para
las abejas de estos insectos depende la
polinización de tres cuartos de cultivos
reconocer son finita karzai diseñar y
blanda
todas estas coníferas se destruyen para
siempre
todo lo tendremos que replantar la
destrucción de un bosque como éste
provoca la desaparición de la fauna y de
los pastos para las abejas
porque todos esos incendios destruyen
las flores de finales de verano y
principios de otoño
la tarde está del primer turno
sin flores sin néctar para alimentar a
las abejas así que para salvar a los
supervivientes fortunato apicultor desde
hace 28 años no tiene otra opción por
primera vez ha optado por la nutrición
artificial
puesto que esa es una preparación dulce
la ponemos para compensar la falta de
alimento natural de lo contrario
corremos el riesgo de que la familia de
abejas muera durante el invierno
no alcanza para salvar la producción de
miel este año la industria ha caído en
un 70% esta es una crisis sin
precedentes que empujó a las autoridades
de la región a declarar un estado de
calamidad para el sector apícola con
cecilia
y seguimos enfocados en la protección
del medio ambiente y para eso vamos a
esta costa de marfil donde nació el
llamado ejército verde una unidad creada
por el gobierno en el año 2018 y
compuesta por 650 soldados que tienen
una única misión encargarse de la
protección de los bosques del país ellos
utilizan herramientas tecnológicas para
detectar actividades ilegales y además
se encargan de educar a la comunidad el
siguiente es un reportaje de esa miel
bernard
si tu trabajo
concentrados y armados el escuadrón
especial de vigilancia e intervención se
prepara para la misión del día estos
hombres forman parte de un ejército
verde de 650 soldados que se han
desplegado por todo el país hombres
entrenados para luchar pero también
especializados en agroforestería puede
comandar de diarra la creación del
escuadrón surgió de la observación
en un punto el gobierno se dio cuenta de
que la deforestación estaba llegando a
otro nivel
como atraparon del hombre de darle desde
la independencia hasta ahora a costa de
marfil han perdido el 70 por ciento de
los bosques que puso en juego pero es
que
la cubierta forestal de costa de marfil
está cada vez amenazada por la actividad
humana desde la tala ilegal y la
extracción de oro hasta el cultivo
clandestino de cacao con solo estudio
pero así es la vigilancia tenemos que
movernos todo el tiempo ser rápidos y
estar al tanto de todo
manteniendo un ojo en el suelo y también
por encima de él el escuadrón utiliza
drones que pueden cubrir grandes
expansiones de tierra y detectar
actividades ilegales
fuera se crean campamentos en estos
bosques protegidos
no podemos detectarlos desde el suelo
pero gracias al throne podemos verlos y
acceder a ellos este proyecto y sus tips
en un bosque público cercano donde no se
permiten la tala la brigada acaba de
descubrir un montón de madera en
cuestión de minutos se encuentran
sospechosos
después de una persecución de media hora
los soldados arrestaron a tres jóvenes
pero después de interrogarlos la unidad
se ve obligada a dejarlos ir por falta
de pruebas tangibles
de qué forma la actividad y
desafortunadamente los hombres que
capturamos no son responsables pero
nunca jamás abandonarán a sus amigos se
les dé un consejo y trate de hacerles
entender que nuestra acción es lo mejor
para todos que lo que hacemos es por
nuestros hijos por nuestro pulmón que el
comprendo que ese conocido no se pone
las gafas primero
más allá de la vigilancia educar a las
comunidades rurales sobre el ecosistema
del bosque y su fragilidad es una de las
misiones centrales del escuadrón la
agricultura en costa de márfil sigue
siendo responsable del 60 por ciento de
la destrucción de los bosques
y regresamos al sáhara occidental' una
región en conflicto que es además el
mayor campo de minas del mundo entre 7 y
10 millones de minas antipersonas
antitanque y bombas de racimo sin
estallar siguen diseminadas a lo largo
de los 2700 kilómetros del muro
construido por marruecos en los años 80
durante la primera guerra del sahara
estas municiones de efecto
siguen estallando décadas después no
tirando piernas y acabando con vidas de
manera indiscriminada el siguiente es un
reportaje de telmo net y diego ibarra
sánchez
sidi mohamed tiene 15 años pero volvió a
nacer el 8 de diciembre de 2020 fue
lanzado por los aires después de que
pisara accidentalmente una mina
enterrada mientras trabajaba con el
rebaño de ovejas no tiene movilidad en
su pie izquierdo
estoy herido de guerra de una guerra que
terminó hace 30 años
ojalá pudiera ir con mis amigos a jugar
al fútbol
también quería ser militar de mayor pero
tengo que ir con estas muletas el resto
de mi vida no las tocan donde se salva
uno es un punto que estoy actúan siete
millones de minas terrestres y
proyectiles de efecto que se
encuentran a lo largo del muro
construido por marruecos durante la
primera guerra del sahara están sin
estallar con la reanudación de los
bombardeos los desminado se han
convertido en todo un reto vamos a tener
que doblar esfuerzos que limpiar de
nuevo que corre hacernos miedo
exploración para marcar esta zona para
que no caen víctimas de nuevo las minas
antipersonas y las bombas de racimo
diseminadas recuerdan que aunque la
guerra lleva enterrada desde hace mucho
tiempo siguen desplazando y matando a
los civiles pero además de las minas los
bombardeos del ejército marroquí también
atentan contra la población saharaui
cientos de familias de beduinos como la
dejar bajar y que se dedican al pastoreo
han huido y ahora viven en campamentos
argelinos de tindúf como refugiados
fuimos tras la guerra era muy peligroso
estábamos muy cerca del muro cogimos los
camellos y recorrimos 300 kilómetros
hasta llegar a un sitio más seguro
separados por un mar de tiendas y dunas
y de harvard junto a casi 2 millones de
saharauis ven como se aleja de nuevo el
sueño de regresar a sus hogares ahora
que la guerra ha vuelto a llamar a las
puertas del desierto
y seguimos en áfrica donde el acceso a
la atención médica muchas veces puede
convertirse en una verdadera lucha en
las zonas más remotas en el extremo
norte del todo las mujeres de la
comunidad culta macu víctimas del cáncer
de mama son muchas veces abandonadas por
sus esposos además muchas de ellas no
cuentan con los recursos suficientes
para pagarse un tratamiento convencional
y terminan en manos de curanderos el
siguiente es un reportaje de manuel
shogi rafael en tablet y emanuel donde
en la región extremadamente aislada de
kuta macu en el extremo norte de togo el
acceso a la atención médica es muy
limitado ni otro sufre cáncer de mama
desde hace unos diez años fue
diagnosticada poco después de su
matrimonio al principio pensé que era
una maldición de una de mis rivales que
estaba en contra de mi matrimonio pero
cuando puedo de ir al hospital me
explicaron que tenía cáncer de mama
cuando a nieto le diagnosticaron cáncer
de mama avanzado su esposo la envió de
inmediato con sus padres cuando me
enferme pude trabajar como debía para
poder satisfacer todas las demandas de
mi esposo entonces me pidió que volviera
con mi padre
de regreso a casa con sus padres que la
cuidan nieto no trabaja cuando tiene
dolor
generalmente las parejas jóvenes no
tienen los medios a menudo cuando se
enfrentan a problemas graves los jóvenes
abandonan a sus esposas y yo soy su
padre incubándola a mi hija tenga uno de
los medios
para ayudarla los padres de nieto pagan
el tratamiento que le brinda a un
curandero tradicional en una aldea
vecina no pueden pagar sus tarifas
hospitalarias ni sus medicamentos
recetados
hace tres años cuando vino aquí no podía
ponerse de pie que tomó un año tratar su
condición para que empezara a mejorar
nunca pensé que la vería viva pero de
vez en cuando ella sufre mucho y le doy
de hierbas por falta de dinero no va al
hospital pero si pudiera pagar lo iría
en el norte de togo donde casi ocho de
cada diez personas viven en la pobreza
la atención médica sigue siendo
inaccesible no sólo desde el punto de
vista financiero sino también
geográficamente llegar a un hospital que
trata el cáncer requiere viajar al menos
500 kilómetros hasta el uml en la
capital de todo
tesla la gigante estadounidense
fabricante de vehículos eléctricos
abrirá su primera mega fábrica en europa
a finales de este año eso ocurrirá en
gran haydée al este de la capital
alemana una fábrica que tomó dos años en
ser construida donde se crearían medio
millón de autos eléctricos cada año y se
generarían miles de empleos impulsando
la economía local sin embargo esta
medida no ha sido bien recibida por
muchos los ambientalistas critican la
tala de bosques y denuncian presuntos
riesgos para los recursos hídricos de la
región el siguiente es un reportaje de
nik spicer jan mayén
la meta final está a la vista para tesla
el fabricante de automóviles
estadounidense comenzó a construir su
fábrica cerca de berlín hace dos años y
está por concluir la albert cooler le
siguió el paso
cool eres fotógrafo aficionado creció en
la región en su cuenta de twitter donde
habla de tesla tiene seguidores de todo
el mundo
es una gran oportunidad para la región
pero también para los jóvenes que viven
aquí y que ya no tendrán que irse para
encontrar un buen trabajo el jefe de
tesla elon musk prometió que se crearán
unos 12.000 puestos de trabajo también
agradeció a los lugareños en alemán
gracias a todos los que han apoyado a
nuestro proyecto esta fiesta es para
ustedes
[Música]
a principios de octubre algunas personas
se les permitió entrar a la planta de
tesla para verla de cerca pero no todos
los locales están entusiasmados con la
llegada de la compañía en las puertas de
la empresa un grupo predice el impacto
ambiental que ésta traería
la fábrica está justo en medio de un
área de protección del agua es una
catástrofe para el medio ambiente local
si surge un problema en la fábrica el
nivel freático se contaminará y eso
afectará también a ciertos barrios de
berlín
pero en brandenburgo donde la industria
se ha extinguido en gran medida la
llegada de tesla promete un futuro mejor
los políticos locales la apoyan
desde la reunificación y así durante los
últimos 30 años ninguna empresa que
cotiza en bolsa- se ha instalado en el
este de alemania así que tesla busca
echar raíces y es un momento muy
importante para la región lo vio
según él en moscú el primer test lab
fabricado en alemania debería salir en
noviembre y sería el primero de 10.000
semanales
gracias por acompañarnos en esta nueva
emisión de corresponsales nos damos cita
la próxima semana siga con más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom